professor jeremy brown sits on the uk's
joint committee
on vaccination and immunisation thank
you very much for being
with us today and before we get to
viewers questions i've just got a couple
from myself if you wouldn't mind
um half of uk adults have now received
their first dose of a vaccine a huge
milestone of course
but there are issues with supply over
the next month
how concerned should we be about those
issues
and do you think they will definitely be
resolved after four weeks
uh the truth for us to say good morning
cindy is is i don't really
know because the supply side of things
is not really what the jcbi is involved
with
i mean it does look like we are i mean
we have been
making a vaccine program which is doing
almost 5 million a week which would have
been a fantastic
uh result if we could maintain that but
it's always been supply a vaccine that
has been the concern that might delay
things
and and yes i suspect our vaccine
program will be delayed
slightly compared to where we thought it
might have been a few weeks ago
but then at that point we're actually
ahead of schedules so we're probably
going to fall back to
the original schedule and end up with uh
everyone who's an adult being offered
your vaccine by
towards the middle to end of the summer
okay so
yeah not not too long to wait then for
uh all adults certainly
um now as you say we've been making some
great progress we're going to vaccinated
all the top nine priority groups
and by mid-april they account for 99 of
deaths in the first wave
at the beginning of the program we heard
from steve baker who was saying that
because of the success of the
vaccination program
we should now look at lifting some of
the restrictions
um what's your take on that okay
this is this is a a slightly complicated
and tricky thing to describe but
at the moment we have roughly sort of
90 95 of people who have been
who are high risk being vaccinated but
that
five or ten percent of people is still a
significant number
and also we've mainly done one dose of
vaccine which gives
most of the protection but not all of
the protection until we've done the
second dose in everybody's been
vaccinated
there is a little degree of infection
that still occur
so if you completely lift all
restrictions there will be
a wave of infections crossing the
country and those that are not protected
either because the first vaccine hasn't
worked very well in them and they need
their second dose
or because they have not had a vaccine
at this point in time but are still
vulnerable
they will get infections and they will
probably end up in hospital
and diet so if you lift restrictions
there this even though most people are
at risk of being vaccinated
the proportion that not still represents
a very large number of people who could
end up with serious infection
that's a very clear explanation thank
you and
there has of course been some people who
are slightly hesitant about getting a
vaccine a bit worried and of course what
we've seen
in europe with the astrazeneca vaccine
may not have helped things and just take
france
as an example first they only allowed
that jab for the under 65s then it was
suspended then the suspension was lifted
now it's only allowed for over 55s the
president described it as
quasi-effective of course
and then the prime minister took it and
do you think some of this is more about
politics and science
okay so that's a i can't i can't answer
for the politicians and why they're
making certain statements
but i don't think the vaccine committees
in the different countries are making
their decisions because of politics
but i do think they've been misguided in
the way they've approached this where
they felt that the precautionary
principle was that
because of the issue raised about blood
clots they should stop the vaccination
program the astrazeneca until they
looked into it whereas in fact
actually if you looked at the data it
was unlikely to be a serious issue in
the first place
and the benefit of the vaccine far
outweighs any potential risk
due to blood clots etc so i mean the
the numbers are like you know one
hundred thousand four more likely
that you would die of covid and at the
vaccine prevent that
then anything could possibly happen the
blood clots
so i think stopping and starting the
program
was a strategic error by the other
countries and could it left to more
deaths
well yes literally i mean i think it's a
bit complicated
because again you stop the vaccine
program for a few days what that means
is that
the the vaccine program is pushed back
by a few days and perhaps maybe the
scheme of things that's not a great
uh a great loss but actually
at this point in time they are having a
third wave of infections so
actually it does represent a delay in
the vaccine program
just when they need it the most so i do
think that was
not well thought out okay let's um bring
in some questions from viewers we've had
a great response actually and this one
from jeanette on instagram
she asks i got the fuzzy jab first time
well i definitely get it from a second
jab because i'm reading there may be a
shortage of pfizer
in the next few months yeah as far as i
understand yeah i'm not
an expert on supply but the everyone who
said the fires the first time would get
the flight of the second time and
astrazeneca ditto the same they get
astro tanker for the second time
and the supply has been matched to allow
that to happen so that should happen
reassuring news there for jeannette and
this is a question we've got through
twitter
once we've vaccinated the top nine
cohorts in the uk
and we have enough supply for second
doses doesn't it make sense to assist
the rest of europe where deaths and
hospitalizations are rising
yeah this one i i struggle with this a
little bit i have to say
i mean there's a certain amount of i
like to get the whole country sorted as
quickly as possible
but the issue about vaccinating the rest
of the world there's an ethical and also
a self-interest
uh in doing so i i suppose the question
is what can we do to help
the europeans with their vaccine program
and i don't actually think that the uk
can help that much because supply isn't
necessarily the problem anymore in
europe
and it's the sort of the roll out and
how you deliver it
how you convince the local population to
take it which is the problems
and those really are local questions for
the european countries themselves
i think it's a different question for
the developing world where
delivering the vaccines in the
developing world is going to be an
immense task and very complex and
i do believe the uk should uh contribute
to that in a big way as much as it can
okay
and this is a question from joe edwards
we've got a lot of similar questions to
this actually
um she asks what is the plan for
immunosuppressed people
i've had both doses of the vaccine but i
haven't developed any antibodies what's
the plan okay so this is quite
close to my heart because my clinical
practices i look after people got lung
problems
who with leukemia or bone marrow
transplants and the infection in that in
that population is a big issue due to
their weak immune systems
so the first thing i can say i can be a
little bit reassuring is that
uh the question i've seen in the in the
email is that
actually she's not developed antibodies
to the vaccine the question
that actually may not reflect that she
has no immune system
response to the vaccine because there
are multiple levels to the immune
response to the vaccine
the antibody that the nhs measures is
the antigen and you would not get an
antibody response to that
if you've been vaccinated because it
doesn't the vaccine doesn't contain the
energy it contains the
spike yes antigen
i'm sorry great answer to that question
uh definitely um
will be a bit of reassurance there i
think for joe um
simon usher posted this question on
instagram
how long will the covered vaccine last
before having to receive
additional doses in the future yeah
the simple answer is i don't know and
nobody knows because we've not had long
enough to see i mean what we need to
know is what the anti-quality response
looks like 12 months after vaccination
and as the clinical trials were
published from november december last
year we're going to have to wait until
autumn before we can actually answer
that question with any degree of
confidence and just final
a final question here this is from
twitter's from kieran
um he asks what's the point of vaccines
if once everyone eligible has had the
jab we're still expected to follow mask
on social distancing rules
i don't expect this to be asked because
it rocks the bait which of course makes
me really want to ask this question
um so what is what is the point of
vaccines yeah
i think i answered that question a
little bit earlier i mean i think
essentially until we can suppress
infection going around the country which
means vaccinating
everybody then some degree of social
distancing or protection is going to be
required just because
even a small proportion of people have
not been vaccinated
or where the vaccine has not worked very
well will be a higher risk of disease
if we have no control of infection
and the control of the infection comes
in once
a very high proportion of the country
being vaccinated we now know that the
vaccine does prevent transmission of the
degree
but that only works on a population
level once you've
vaccinated a high proportion of the
population so that's that's phase two of
the vaccine program
that's some really fascinating answers
there i'm sure that and the viewers will
be really happy with those responses uh
just one final one from me if i may
before we let you go
um just to clarify um are you expecting
every adult in the uk to have received
the first dose by the end of july or do
you think that could now slip into
august i don't know i think july august
those are the ballpark areas where where
we would hope
that every adult has been offered their
first phase of the vaccine
okay that and that is very helpful thank
you so much for being on the program
thank you for asking our
questions as well much appreciated bye